[Musique]
le département et les représentants des
associations cultuelles de la réunion
présente les commémorations qui auront
lieu le 11 novembre prochain au lazaret
de la grande chaloupe depuis plusieurs
années maintenant un hommage commun est
rendu aux ancêtres aux engagés venus par
la mer de petits de spots et aux
cérémonies des services offre à compter
conclure les deux pourquoi ce sens poids
dont consiste à
se tourner une fois de plus on va vers
les verts 16 ans cette fois là vers 16
heures ils vont
débarquer en tant qu'engagé à leur
rendre hommage en leur demandant la
bénédiction de leur bénédiction d'être
là je le 11 novembre 2 n'oubliez pas que
la fin de langage et ça a été c'était en
nous mêmes nous sommes des enfants
d'engager et il est de notre devoir
aujourd'hui de pouvoir commémorer cette
date et de faire honneur à ses engagés
et quelles que soient les régions de
donner des points d'entrée obligatoire
en débarquant sur l'île le lazaret de la
grande chaloupe est aujourd'hui un lieu
de mémoire au coeur de l'histoire de la
quarantaine et de l'engagisme un site
emblématique pour ces commémorations du
11 novembre
le rendez vous est donné à 9 heures 30
sur le parking du lazaret numéro 1 pour
ensuite démarré la procession à 10
heures la procession vers la mer
accompagné des tambours indien et lâche
sur la grève chaque communauté sera
invité à rendre hommage
les unes après les autres à leurs
ancêtres engagé ensuite on revient vers
11h au lazaret numéro un pour un temps
des sols un temps des changes un temps
de parole n'offrent un mot un temps
culturelles aux participants la
commémoration avec cette année la visite
du chantier de consolidation du lazaret
numéro deux chantiers qui habituellement
fermés au public et l'inauguration de
l'oeuvre terre à l'horizon de noémie
sjoeberg des échanges cultuelles et
culturelles seront proposées aux
visiteurs ce jeudi une journée pour
comprendre et se rappeler de là où tout
a commencé
[Musique]